so welcome to this talk about escaping
from WCF and embracing the brave new
world of GRP see why you'd want to do
that how easy or difficult it's likely
to be and various other bits and pieces
I am mark Rendell you may remember me
from very stupid talks and some
technical talks that went quite well but
at the moment so Microsoft when they
announced this last year that WCF was
going away I somehow got involved and
then I ended up writing a book on how to
migrate from WCF to gr PC which you can
get on the website on Microsoft's
website and I've started building a tool
to do it as well it's not a marketing
session for the toll I'm not going to
show you it I'm not going to demonstrate
it all I am gonna say is that everything
I show you it will do automatically with
two clicks so just bear that in mind so
here we are at the start of 2020 don't
make all three point one is out that's a
long term service release and the future
of Dom net looks like this so we have
dotnet core 3.1 that came out in
November 2019 then version 5 will be out
this November and don't net 5 so it's
not dotnet core 4 because that would be
too confusing
yeah it's donate 5 because everybody
understands what that means it means
donek 4 is dead and you should stop
using it and Microsoft would really
really like it if you stopped using it
because then they could take all the
developers that make the patch is to do
with time zones changing I think that's
the only reason they change dotnet for
now is that someone moves a time zone
but yes don't make 5 it's mono it's
dotnet core is xamarin it's the whole
stack moving forward and then once a
year in
November every year we'll get a new
dotnet release oh that's what Microsoft
claimed and so don't met past we have
things that have been brought across to
dotnet v and dotnet three point what
call three point one not confusing at
all but we have things that are not
being brought across a WPF and windows
forms are both in dotnet core 3.1 only
if you run it on Windows because
Microsoft but they're there and they
work and Microsoft will continue to
support those until they convince
everyone that the best way to make
desktop applications is blazer and run
it in electron or something they don't
think so things that are not going into
dotnet core and dotnet 5 web forms is
not making it across and you're supposed
to use blazer instead so as anyone who's
going to blazer talks or has been to a
blazer talk it looks quite good at the
moment it's it looks the server-side
blazer thing I'm just kind of that can't
be right
I thought viewstate was bad we're just
going to keep an open signal our
connection further yet but blazer
webassembly looks quite exciting I quite
like the idea that blazer webassembly
they download a web assembly version of
technically the mono runtime and then
they just download dll's
like il dll's and they run them in the
browser and so I'm thinking if that's
the mono runtime then does that include
Manos implementation of system dot web
and if it does can we download that into
the browser and compile our web forms
applications to dll's
and then download the web forms dll's
into the browser and actually run web
forms inside blazer
and I'm actually has somebody already
done that and that's what we're all
living in the universe is actually just
this is a side-effect of someone running
a web forms in a browser in a higher
existence so yes if you've got millions
of lines of web forms that you need
support to Blaser I'm sorry there's
really nothing you can do it well that
WCF is not coming across and that's what
we're going to talk about now too
switching to gr PC which is Microsoft's
recommendation and then this workflow
foundation hands up who used workflow
foundation okay I swear to god I've done
this talk half a dozen times that's the
first time I've seen hands
Wow workflow foundation is actually
getting an open source port full
disclosure so is WCF but w CF s-- open
source port is gonna be a lot more
challenging for them to implement
properly and by the time you get to
things like MSM cube bindings well
that's going away and distributed
transaction controllers good luck
getting networking in a kubernetes
cluster but workflow foundation relies
less on those things and so there is an
open source port of that so WCF
specifically WCF had it was incredibly
flexible and one of the main reasons
that dotnet development teams adopted
WCF back in 2008 2009 was because
everybody was doing soap soap over HTTP
because that's the solution to
distributed systems engineering it's to
wrap a single digit in two kilobytes of
namespace infested XML
so that you can send it over the wire to
a client that's been generated from yet
another big pile of namespace infested
XML and you could do all this just by
writing a simple class and about four
hundred lines of namespace infested XML
we loved XML back in the back in the
2000 was didn't we I was the best but
the great thing if you use WCF with soap
over HTTP then it could play nicely with
other platforms it could talk to Java or
it could talk to Python there weren't
other platforms apart from those too I
don't think did Ruby ever do soap could
you write let probably but yes if you
wanted to interoperate with other
systems then soap WCF was very good for
that the basic HTTP binding and then you
had WCF with net tcp and net tcp opened
a TCP connection on HTTP connection just
a raw socket connection and you had a
dotnet application at one end and a
dotnet application at the other end and
they could talk to each other and have
asynchronous conversations and it was a
binary protocol and very very efficient
and incredibly fast and you could stream
things in both directions at the same
time the problem with net TCP Microsoft
very optimistically said here is the
specification for net TCP Java people
would you like to implement that in Java
so that you could talk to our net TCP
services and the Java people when know
so if you used net TCP it was a dotnet
application talking to a dotnet
application at which point you might as
well use dotnet remoting so and of
course the configuration feed
I hated configuring WCF I absolutely
hated it because they didn't have like
decent functioning intellisense
for the xml at the time cuz that's quite
difficult to do and you couldn't
configure it in cut these days we can do
configuration in code and you just have
like action callbacks that pass in
builder objects and you set properties
on them and then it just magically
happens but no XML it's XML all the way
down and so now Microsoft are saying
we're not supporting WCF moving forward
WCF is not coming do not make call get
over it and my grades to GRP see who
makes G RPC Google what does the G in G
RPC stand for currently anything but
Google according to google it stands for
glamorous I think was was won every time
they release a new update to it they
changed what the G stands for it's just
never Google that's why it's a lowercase
G so you know it's not Google but G RPC
essentially is an attempt to solve the
same problem that WCF attempted to solve
which is of course remote procedure
calls G RPC is based on protoboys so
protobuf existed first and protobuf is
google's serialization framework and
format and specification and with
protobuf you create a file that
describes your data object and then you
use a file compiler that generates
Python or Java or C++ or net or you can
even these days even though it's all
still the JVM you can get different
compilers that compile it to scholar or
Kotlin or closure but yes it generates
these stubs that mean everything can
talk this same language it's also
incredibly small over the network
minimal possible size and very very fast
to serialize and deserialize
so the CPU time involved in decoding and
encoding is also very low as well as the
network latency and it's really quite
simple it's it's very straightforward
and quite limited in some ways but
incredibly powerfully in other ways so
then on top of this they built G our PC
they had an internal project called
stubby which was their own RPC framework
and stubby had some very very hairy C
and C++ code in there and they
distributed it as a as a linked library
and that could be used by their
plaything stuff and their Java stuff and
their C++ stuff but it was really very
Google specific if there were ever any
problems with it they just hacked more
lines of code into it to fix that
problem for that particular user and it
had become unmanageable and then HTTP 2
came along or rather quick no not quick
what was it speedy speedy came along
which was Google's attempt to improve
HTTP and then speedy became HTTP 2 and
everyone adopted it and that was cool
and then they went actually HTTP 2 does
most of the complicated stuff that
stubby does in terms of framing and
duplexing and streaming and everything
else let's rewrite stubby over the top
of HTTP 2 and so they did that and
called it G RPC and it works exactly the
same as protobuf so you gently describe
your service in a dot proto file and
then you use the compiler and it
generates source code in whatever
language you ask it to and then you just
implement the services and it creates
clients for other services and
everything else so with G RPC we get
because it's a binary format we get the
benefits of net TCP style performance
and because HTTP 2 supports multiplexing
connections you're doing a brilliant job
that
sign language for multiplexing but yes
and bi-directional streaming and
everything else so it can do everything
that net TCP can do but it supports more
platforms and frameworks and languages
than were ever able to talk soap it's
quite a lot of them are officially
supported but then there are unofficial
implementations for more cutting-edge
things like rust has a gr PC compiler
implementation so you get the benefit of
soap and interoperability but without
XML and you get the benefit of net TCP
but your clients and servers can be all
different platforms and languages here's
a list of everything that G RPC supports
dotnet Java Python Dart
so if you're doing flutter then you can
create a gene RPC client for your
flutter application in Dart elixir and
Erlang separately and so if you're
creating telephone switchboards that
need G RPC you can do that
Haskell because high school programmers
haven't got anything real to write so
they just run around looking for
projects to do the one thing so it
supports JavaScript but only in node
because it's actually a wrapper around
the G RPC native library it doesn't
directly support the web browser because
the web browser the HTTP to
implementation you don't have enough
control over it from JavaScript to do
the things that gr PC wants to do with
HTTP to solution to that was to create a
tiny little proxy service that you could
run on the same machine or in the same
local network as your g RPC service that
would then expose it as WebSockets
i think
and then your browser application could
connect to that and talk to that over
WebSockets or HTTP and it would pass
proxy the messages on which is quite
cool and you know if you really need to
be able to talk to it from the browser
then that's a great solution I literally
saw this on Monday as I was finishing
off the prep for this talk and James
Newton King who works on the G RPC for
asp net core implementation they've got
an experimental thing which they have
released as a NuGet package which does
the G RPC web protocol natively inside
your asp net called g RPC application so
you don't need that additional process
so it'll run the G RPC service but it
will also run that proxy in the same
process so that your browser
applications can connect to it as well
so you don't need that proxy server
running for your web stuff having that
chance to play with it yet but it looks
quite cool and if it does work it will
be brilliant
so asp net cord g RPC you've actually
been able to do G RPC and donate for a
very long time there is an official
first party implementation it's been
supported by the Google team that works
on G RPC for years but it is a bunch of
pea invoke wrappers over the G RPC
native library that's written in C and
that comes with all the overhead of P
invoke and marshaling and everything
else that goes on with that sort of
thing
Microsoft wanted a fully managed
implementation that would play nicely
with the rest of the asp net core
hosting model things like dependency
injection and kestrel and all that sort
of stuff and so they said hey let's
write our own implementation of G RPC
but because this is 2020s Microsoft and
not 2010's Microsoft they're actually
doing it in the G RPC github
organization so this is Microsoft
getting code 2g RPC which makes asp net
core do it so it's a fully managed
implementation part of the GRP see it's
maintained by Microsoft people including
James Newton King who did Jason net so
you know he's quite good at the
serialization stuff it runs on the
Kestrel HTTP server which means it is
ridiculously fast like 99.99999% as fast
as the fastest web server in the world
and there's also a client generator and
the client-side uses HTTP client which
is also got bonkers fast over the last
couple of races of dotnet call setting
it up in your asp net core application
it's literally just adding a couple more
things to startup so we say services
don't add GRP see if I've done yes I
have services don't add G RPC hooks it
up as long as you've created the
application with GRP C libraries
referenced and then in configure we have
endpoints map G RPC service portfolio
service that's that's basically it
that's now hooked up your G RPC service
you can add other endpoints in there you
can have an MVC application or a razor
pages application or just standard
endpoints map get map put and that sort
of thing in the same application you
shouldn't but you can what you'll
actually see if you sort of do dotnet
new G RPC is they say map the T RPC
service and then just put an HTTP GET
that catches any HTTP request after it
that says this is a G RPC server
stop trying to access it from your
browser so yes that's that's basically
it
to create your actual to say I need this
service and it does this thing and this
is what my the stuff that you would have
done with service contracts and data
contracts and operation contracts and
data members and everything else we now
have the dot prototype file so we use
that to describe our service and then
the build process and this is included
in the MS build process so Visual Studio
will just run it in the background or it
will happen when you do the build on
your continuous integration server and
then you derive from the generated class
and override some methods and that's
where you put your actual implementation
so it's a bit different from WCF WCF you
created an interface and decorated it
with the attributes and that was in
c-sharp and then you implemented the
interface using another class or
whatever else and then it would generate
the WSDL file for other people who
wanted to consume your service and they
could generate their client from that
WSDL file here we effectively handwrite
the WSDL file that's what the proto file
is is the description of the service
don't worry it's much simpler than WSDL
then they won't ever hand written a WSDL
file there's always one respect so yes
you write that file but it's it's like
code and then you derive from the class
that it generates for you in c-sharp
this is a prototype file this is very
very simple it's got an option with a
c-sharp namespace you can have all sorts
of options in your profile for different
platforms so if somebody else who's not
using c-sharp compiles this to java then
it will just ignore that c-sharp
namespace and if you get a profile from
somebody else you'll probably see a
whole bunch of options related to the
code
Jennifer other platforms that you don't
care about the package name that's
important that becomes part of the URL
for the service and then you have the
service and you have our pcs and an RPC
has a name that takes an object and
returns another object and that's
basically it
and then you have your message
definitions which look like this so we
have a portfolio message and a portfolio
item message and protobuf supports a set
of data types and natively and it
doesn't support any other data types
natively but it's quite extensible and
so there are ways of creating more
complex types but in 32 is just a 32-bit
integer there is also u int 32 for an
unsigned 32-bit integer and there's s
int 32 for a signed 32-bit integer
because of course you need int 32 is
also signed but if you know that your
number is going to have a lot of
negative values then you should use s
int 32 because the encoding is more
efficient if there think yeah we have
double we have string byte arrays we
don't have arrays we just have the
repeated keyword and that will in
c-sharp that will generate a collection
for you of type portfolio item and then
the other thing you'll notice oh my
field names are wrong here
I've used camelcase this is from some
old code that should be snake underscore
Train case according to the G RPC
standards
yes the last thing is on the end you see
there is a number by each one of those
fields and that is very important that
number identifies that field in the
binary protocol so it doesn't put the
name in it puts the number a actually
combines the field number with another
number that represents the type into a
single byte if it can the first 15
fields encode one byte smaller than all
the other fields but that number says
the first field in portfolio the number
one field in portfolio will always be a
32-bit integer and specifically that
type of 32-bit integer and it will
always be used for the ID if you change
your object then you can add more fields
and you can remove existing fields that
you reserved the number and this means
that no matter how your service evolves
theoretically it should always be
possible for an older version of the
client to talk to a newer version of the
server and even for a newer version of
the server to talk to an older version
of the client so those field numbers are
incredibly important and very useful one
more thing which I know it's going to
please everybody in the room who cares
about money protobuf doesn't have a
decimal type it has double
yeah I know now the thing is that's
actually okay because if you turn a
decimal into a double its serializes
fine it maintains that value absolutely
fine and if you then turn it back into a
decimal at the other end it's not going
to randomly change it that's not the
problem
the problem is where someone pulls down
your repeated portfolio item items and
then runs a link aggregation over the
generated protobuf class which has got a
double in it and says what is five times
four point nine nine and of course as we
all know that's twenty-four point nine
four nine nine nine nine nine nine nine
nine nine nine nine nine nine eight nine
bigger cities so but you can create your
own decimal type quite easily
you just need units and menos basically
so that's quite easy so here is what the
implementation looks like the protobuf
compiler or msbuild in our case has
generated a portfolios portfolios base
class for us and that declares virtual
methods for all the methods we declared
in a proto file in this instance get and
our methods the base class method takes
a get request and also a server call
context which is gr pcs equivalent of
HTTP context and it has useful
information about things like
authentication and it returns a task of
get response it's always asynchronous
because it should be
it will only ever take one parameter so
you can't have multiple parameters to an
RPC if you have multiple parameters you
wrap them up into an object and it will
always return a message so you have to
declare a message type for it to return
you can't just return an int you have to
wrap that int in a message over the wire
that doesn't really do anything but
it's there are very good reasons for
this mainly to do with forward and
backward compatibility so by only taking
that message type as a parameter it's
impossible to break the interface as
long as you don't break that message
which as long as you keep your field
numbers in line you will never do if you
change the parameter list for a WCF
contract method that's it all those
generated clients out there won't work
and if you're using net TCP bindings
good luck decoding those error messages
equally you have to also have to return
a response there's no such thing as a
void RPC it has to return a response
that response can be empty and quite
often it will be empty if you don't care
there's no information to come back you
return an empty response but again if at
some point in the future you suddenly
went you know what it would be quite
easy quite useful to get the number of
rows that are updated in the database
back from that method so you add a field
to that response object and again you
haven't broken binary compatibility with
existing clients oh yeah
gooood there's no type for guiit in
protobuf or UUID fun thing though when
you come to convert your or try and
represent your gooood in a proto file
you might be tempted as I was to
represent it as a byte array because of
gooood is a byte array yes that's
absolutely fine and then send that over
to someone else and then a Java
programmer will get that byte array and
put it through Java's optimized gooood
byte parser which converts it into
multiple Long's using a different Indian
Miss from c-sharp and you just get a
completely different gooood that comes
out at the other end the really fun
thing is when it C realizes it back
again and sends it back to c-sharp it
doesn't even come out as the gooood that
gets eesh it doesn't just know anyway so
goo it's just use strings everything
understands gooood notation strings or
UUID notations
brings outside of our little dotnet
bubble which is why that says trader ID
must be a UUID so G RPC has several
modes that it supports and they map
fairly well to WCF and I'm going to show
some code examples in a minute of first
a simple request reply service so WCF
basic HTTP binding the sort of thing you
would just do soap you pass a request it
returns a response and that's the
simplest G RPC thing you pass a request
it returns a response WCF with certain
bindings if you returned an ienumerable
from your operation contract method it
could stream those items so it would
send the first one as soon as it was
ready and then they would stream over
one at a time worked very well with net
TCP binding didn't work at all with some
of the other bindings G RPC can return a
stream from the server which you can
then indium or eat over and read the
objects off G RPC can also send so open
a stream to the server and then just
send messages up it which is kind of
like WCF where you've got a operation
contract with one-way methods so it's
fire-and-forget I don't care just do it
don't get back to me w CF s-- most
powerful feature the full duplex so the
client has an interface that it can use
to send message calls to the server and
the server has a callback interface that
it can use to invoke methods on the
client and so you had a two-way
conversation which allowed you to do a
lot of very powerful things G our PC has
bi-directional streaming so you can the
server can return a stream the client
can open a string into the server and
then they can send messages in both
directions completely independently of
each other and then you can write
funky code that will effectively make
that work like full duplex which I will
show you shortly if you're using WCF
with a binding to MSN queue then just
write the code to write it to the queue
and yeah sorry all right a gr piece G
RPC service to write it to the queue and
then use yeah that that's MSM Q
particular software
apparently MSN queue is dead according
to their blog so don't use that anymore
so basic binding looks like this so here
we have a WCF or what used to be a WCF
service contract is the hotel service
it's got method get' available rooms
which takes a date/time offset of a
check-in date and a date/time offset for
the checkout date and returns a list of
rooms we also have a simple method where
you specify the room number and it just
returns that room we have a more
complicated one where you specify a list
of numbers and it returns the matching
list of rooms and then finally we have a
streaming method where you just say just
get me all the rooms but bearing in mind
that that could be those big Hilton
hotels just over the river that's a lot
of rooms so don't build a massive list
on the server and send it over all at
once the implementation for that we just
implement that interface and we've got
our data repository and we're just going
to return a list here and we're going to
return a room there and all rooms is
returning an ienumerable service a very
thin wrapper around effectively a
repository class and now a room object
here room has a number it's on the floor
it's got a name just in case it's called
like the Lincoln suite or something and
it's got a price which is a decimal so
to represent
this in a pro to buff file our hotel
service looks very similar I'm going to
make this a little bit bigger can
everyone see that all right at the back
just about good
so yeah hotel service effectively this
becomes our service contract interface
so we're saying it has these methods
they take these request types and they
return these response types so we've
wrapped the parameters for each of those
methods in a G RPC in a pro to buff
message and I've just named those after
the method that they apply to so get
available rooms has a get available
rooms request and returns a get
available rooms response now you might
be tempted at this point to say I'm
going to create a reusable message that
can be shared by multiple services
called rooms list which has just got a
repeated rooms filled in or room filled
inside it it's generally a better idea
to do it this way so for the wrapper
message around your request and your
response create it separately for each
method so that if one of them needs to
add a field to its parameters or add a
field to its response you're not going
to break all the others
so you'll future-proofing your
application this way by duplicating a
little bit of code and you know it's
copy and paste we're programmers we're
good at that
she got the vin plug-in it's yank and
paste so yeah now another type that
protobuf does not have is a date or a
date time or a date time offset what it
does have is something called a well
moment type and as soon as you try and
build anything real in G RPC you will
start needing to use the well-known
types this is a library of protobuf
definitions that are part of the call
system it's like the standard library
for protobuf but they are defined in
protobuf and you can generate the code
for them the same way you can generate
the code for your own profile date/time
offset and date/time both map nicely to
timestamp timestamp does actually
include timezone information so it's
strictly it's more like date time offset
than date time so we import google slash
protobuf slash timestamp proto and then
down here we use the message type the
field type google.com stamp there is a
standard for this so the path to the
import that doesn't actually exist
anywhere on disk the compiler just knows
about it it's built into the compiler
but the name of the type is always the
path with the slash is replaced with
dots and then pascal case on the thing
at the end
so slash protobuf slash timestamp
becomes dot protobuf timestamp and here
I've actually got my proper case on the
fields we have to get room requests and
to get rooms requests and we have an all
rooms request doesn't take any
parameters so I just declare an empty
object if later on I decide I want to
add a parameter to all the rooms then I
can and I don't break any existing
clients you just have to write code for
these by the way you have to sort of say
if that feels not set then do something
sensible you can't just add
field and then assume that it will
always be said it might not be but that
is just again that's just programming we
have a repeated room values in the get
available rooms response and room down
here we've got a double for the price
and finally all rooms so all rooms which
was the one that returned an ienumerable
of room is now in its return section
saying I returned a stream of all rooms
response that says this will open a
stream and it will write objects until
there are no more objects and then it
will close that stream again there are
multiple reasons why you might want to
use a stream rather so if you've got ten
rooms and each one is like 50 bytes
worth of data then don't return a string
because it's much quicker to just build
that list in memory encode that list in
one go and fire it back as a single
response but if you've got a thousand
rooms and each one is 500 bytes in
memory and you don't want to use 500 K
of memory building a building the
response then you can use a stream and
send them one at a time equally if
you've just got a bunch of objects and
they take a long time to calculate they
take a long time to construct from
whatever sources and you want the first
one the client can start using the first
one while you're still working on the
others then you can use a stream to give
more responsiveness for your user and
finally maybe you've just got a
notification service maybe you've just
got sort of incoming messages or a
weather service or something and you
just want to infrequently send updates
and so you can do that using a stream as
well so
then we have our room conversion so this
solution was converted from a dotnet
four point seven point two WCF solution
and that solution had this room class in
it which was a date contract and it had
data members which have now been
commented out so this conversion class
has been generated and that's gone into
the proto's folder as well so the proto
smolder is where by convention you put
your prototype files
you don't have to you can put them
anywhere you want but that's where the
boilerplate puts it for you the proto
file has said use hotel core dot proto's
is the namespace and all the classes
that g RPC generates for you are partial
which means you can add functionality to
them and in this case I've added
implicit operators to convert between
the protobuf room message and the old
room data contracts type and you can see
here that it just sets the fields and
calls convert to double on the price and
convert dr decimal on that price there
and then finally the service code itself
so this is my implementation code here
this is where it implements the methods
from the proto file from the service in
the proto file and we inject basically
i've just copied the old service
contract implementation over from the
WCF application and i inject that into
my g RPC service and then for each one
of those requests i just call the
equivalent service contract request
converting check-in dates which is a
protobuf timestamp to the date time
offset and then I create a new get
available rooms response write the
values into responsive Al use and then
because the original code here was
synchronous has a lot of wucf code is I
just returned a task from result on
there similar thing with get room
response and get rooms response just
pulling numbers out and into a race but
essentially all I'm doing here is
mapping from the G RPC request and
response messages and the G RPC methods
to the old service contract method so if
you've got code that basically will work
in dotnet call so you're not using any
new get packages for which there is not
an updated version that works with don't
make call and you're not using horrible
things that are built into the dotnet
framework that nobody even knew about or
you know if you are you can get rid of
them then you should be able to rescue
most of your existing code and just wrap
this G RPC facade around it and carry on
using it as should theoretically be
fairly low effort and you can see here
we have our all rooms so when you
specify streaming for a RPC method you
don't create the stream the GRP C
runtime creates the stream for you and
just goes here you are here's the stream
right to it and so you do that and then
we say for each item in get rooms create
a new all rooms response and then write
that response to the stream and then the
other thing that we really want to do
know that that's fine this is a bit
weird because
this method returns a task when that
task completes the stream will be closed
and the connection will be closed and
the client will will finish and so you
have to keep it inside this method you
have to sort of do an async call you
lose all the async calls you can think
of but don't just start something
running on a background thread and pass
the string to it and then return a
completed task because that will cause G
RPC to go and we're done and if you're
anything like me you'll spend several
hours trying to work out why that
happened
tasks run does not do what you think it
does so that's a duplex service that's
not a duplex service that's a very
simple service and yeah effectively it's
just taking your old boilerplate code
and wrapping it in some new boilerplate
code and then over time you can kind of
refactor it and make it a little bit
more native to G RPC and maybe sort of
pull things out of service contracts and
everything else but you can achieve this
without having to rewrite everything
from scratch I think it's my point if
you can drag your c-sharp files into a
dotnet call 3.1 project and that dotnet
call 3.1 project builds then you can
probably carry on using them the only
thing you will definitely definitely
need to remove data contracts and data
member will actually work those are
still there but service contract
operation contract full contract all the
things that were in system dot service
model those are gone so comment those
out you'll probably be fine
okay so that was request/response basic
binding obviously that's quite
straightforward trying to make duplex
work is a little bit more complicated or
we also saw server streaming there by
the way that all rooms method where it
used to return
innumerable and now it just returns the
service tree but body directional
streaming as a way of doing full duplex
is much more fun and the other thing
that this kind of highlights is that WCF
had this concept of session and you had
instance context mode and you could
basically say when the client opens the
connection starter session
create an instance of the service
contract class and keep it alive until
the client is finished and so if you set
any fields or stored any data in private
fields or properties inside that class
that effectively was your session state
so no load-balancing at all but it did
make it very very easy to have a
continuous conversation going and as
we'll see from microsoft's calculator
example because why wouldn't you
implement a calculator as a full duplex
WCF service that requires net TCP
binding to work so we have our
our calculator interface this would have
been our service contract interface in
our old code this is taken directly from
Microsoft's WCF samples so we have add
to subtract from x divided by all of
which take a double and a clear and all
of these methods return void so no value
goes back from these methods any values
that go back to the client are going to
come through the callback interface and
I call back interface looks like this so
we have a result I've added a result
async just to make my life a bit easier
and an equation and an equation async
and so anytime the server wants to
communicate data back to the client it
does it by invoking a method now WCF did
some really hairy stuff it basically
used run time reflection and ILM it to
generate an in-memory representation of
that callback class that Marshall method
calls to net TCP sockets and everything
else we're not going to do that now
instead we are going to abuse or use
bi-directional streaming so service now
it doesn't have all those methods it
doesn't have an add and subtract and
everything else it just has a start and
it creates a client stream of actions
and returns another stream of callbacks
and so our calculator action message
here has a message type you can nest
messages inside other messages which is
a really good way of making sure you
don't get clashes between type names and
so our calculator action has nested
message types for clear and add to and
subtract from and
then it uses a one-off so one of is a
pro to buff keyword and it says here is
a subset of fields within these braces
only one of these can be set and if you
set one of them and then set another one
the first one that you set won't be set
anymore and so this calculator action
will either have a clear or an add to or
a subtract from and you'll be able to
tell which one it is so this is
effectively like a variant type or a
union type it's saying this message will
be one of these things and the callback
same thing we have a result callback and
an equation call back in another one off
filled in there and then we have our
calculator implementation here so this
is matches the service contract
implementation so we have our add two
and our subtract from and everything
else and we have a callback type which
works just like our callback would have
worked in WCF with full duplex binding
except instead of operation context
current get callback contract angle
brackets the type of the callback
contract we're just going to create it
ourselves and pass it in and then our
service and this is the point where it
gets really fun is we have our start
method here and that gives us the
request stream which is the requests
coming in from the client and the
response stream which is the way that we
can write responses to the client and
their cervical context as before and
then because this is not net call 3.1
and we're doing c-sharp 8 we've got a
sink enumerable and so request stream is
a my async stream
but there's an extension method on that
that turns it into an ie async
enumerable of those requests and so we
can just do an a wait for each then we
can have a switch statement and that
action as well as having the fields for
things like clear and add to it
generates an action case enumeration and
a field of that type and that tells you
which one of the fields is set so we can
very quickly switch over that and we can
say if it's a clear message then invoke
the clear method if it's an add to
message invoke the add to method if it's
a subtract from message invoke subtract
from and then down here you can see the
invoke add to async it passes in that
action and it just calls that on the
contract contract was passed in up at
the top here was a factory to create it
in the client code for that because it's
no fun having this so we have a program
dot CS here and we have a calculator
client adapter so it's all very well you
on your team on your server side saying
hey we've created a gr PC version of
this and all you have to do is instead
of implementing a callback interface you
have to subscribe to a stream of
callback messages and decide what you're
going to do according to the type of the
message and whether that's a result
callback or an equation callback and so
to be helpful to our users and also to
remove barriers to adoption we're going
to create library that contains wrapper
around the G RPC client that is
compatible source code compatible with
their old generated WCF client because
we're nice like that and that
essentially just does the same thing but
at the other end so we need to make sure
it started obviously
and then we have a call back to ask
which we're going to run asynchronously
over the response stream you can see
here that this is just essentially when
you call the method on this class it
makes sure this stream has been started
and then it's wraps that up in the right
kind of action so it's creating a new
add to there and then writes that to the
request stream and if we scroll down
here far enough we've got the run
callback and that looks very similar to
the server-side thing
so you're just for each a weight or a
weight for reaching over that stream
with callback messages and then passing
those through to the callback
implementation that was how they used to
get these things back in the WCF days
it's complicated but it does work and
really once you know those patterns it's
quite possible
so sort of repeatable that you can make
a visual studio plug-in that does it
but please don't I don't like
competition so yes but this effectively
this still gives you a way of wrapping
around your existing code and just
wrapping it in a new way of handling
this and of course the advantage is that
once you've done this if you had a
service that only worked with net TCP so
your Java users or other people couldn't
use it if you rewrite it using this way
of doing bi-directional streaming and
firing things backwards and forwards
then you can go to the Python people and
say yes you can generate a Python client
or you can generate a Java client and
everybody can be happy and and work
together and hippie-dippy sort of stuff
like that
the other thing this achieves because
our where's my server calculator service
class gone here so remember the thing
about when you're streaming in either
direction the stream stays open until
that methods the tasks that that method
returns completes so if that method has
to stay open and that method is running
inside of this class which it is because
it's using members of this class then
that's going to keep this instance of
the class alive for as long as the
method is running for for as long as the
stream is open which means in G RPC in a
very hacky bad way we have managed to
implement session in exactly the same
way that WCF used to do it and so if you
every time somebody calls start create
an instance of your service contract
class then you have instance per session
handling the same way that you used to
in WCF which i think is quite nice very
very happy but quite nice all the code
that are showing here will be pushed up
to github and available for you to
download as a reference so yeah security
WCF security was all kinds of fun how
long never got left two minutes that's
fine but yes
so in WCF security was all WS security
and it applied to things like how are we
going to do encryption are we going to
do message level encryption or value
level encryption and also how are we
going to authenticate the user and
authorize the user and there were lots
of different ways of doing this it
integrated with Active Directory and
LDAP and Kerberos and God knows what
else
basically GRP see how is the data going
to be encrypted well this is HTTP - it's
encrypted because it's over TLS
you can do it you can force it to turn
TLS off which is quite handy when you're
running in like a kubernetes cluster and
the networks encrypted anyway so why do
it twice but for public services they're
running over HTTP - that basically
includes TLS so all communications are
encrypted by default and as far as
authentication and authorization goes it
supports certificate authentication so
the client can supply a certificate and
the server can validate that certificate
the server the client can also validate
the server's certificate and so you can
make sure that both those certificates
were generated by the same Authority
which is quite handy for internal
systems and the other thing it supports
for at the call level so the certificate
authentication is handled at the
connection level so when the connection
is opened the certificates are validated
and we go okay so this is a valid client
talking to a valid server if you then
want to do call level authentication you
basically use a token a JSON web token
some kind of bearer token if you have
been using Active Directory Windows ntlm
LDAP Kerberos authentication for your
WCF service then you need to hook up one
of those things that generates a bearer
token from your Active Directory so ad
FS or something similar and then you can
pass that through into your G RPC
service and because Microsoft have got
libraries for understanding ad FS tokens
you can still use them as the
authentication on the server side
because the server authentication is
just asp net core authentication it
works with the same providers you should
use JWT token orth or Roth or octo or
whatever you want to use in production
this is the really nice thing so if you
get a WCF service that used to run on
Windows
20:16 on a server with 32 gigabytes of
RAM and a 4 core and 8 core Xeon
processor and could manage you know a
thousand requests a second you can now
run that same service as a dotnet called
G RPC service on a Raspberry Pi and it
will be able to do 10,000 requests a
second so you can run one thing you
can't do with an asp net core 3.1 g RPC
service is run it in iis you can run it
natively on windows you can run it
behind nginx you can run it behind the
web server proxy you can do
authentication at that proxy you can't
run it in IRS because i is doesn't
implement all of HTTP 2's optional
specifically response trains this is a
matter of waiting for is to catch up and
possibly by the end of this year you
will be able to do that
but you can run it in a docker container
you can run it in a kubernetes pod it
will play nicely with service meshes if
you've got a big production kubernetes
environment or aks or eks or google
cloud or whatever else you might have
this has been a fairly high-level talk
and I've kind of said hey these things
are possible there's a lot more detail
in this book that I wrote and my wife
helped for Microsoft which is on their
docks website if you just google G RPC
for WCF developers it's search engine
optimized it's wait at the top if you
Bing for it it's on like the third page
so don't do that why would you do that
oh I know because Microsoft's had it a
plug into Chrome that does it for you
both the code samples that I've shown
here were generated by visual recode
which is preview 3 is going to be out
next week which does the duplex stuff it
is a commercial product but it will do
an awful lot of this legwork for you and
I'm really hoping it is going to be an
option for people to
excu huge great sways of code without
having to manually play all through and
do everything to pull software are going
to be selling that I'm just making it
that's what it does
so version one we'll just do WCF to
Tihar PC 1.5 will also do WCF rest if
anyone's been using that just turn that
into an asp net core MVC project and
then 2.0 we're gonna look at web api and
then maybe at some point in the future
i'll do that thing with blazer and mono
when system web and just really upset
microsoft that's it I've used all the
time thank you very much for coming I
hope that was useful I'm around for the
rest of the conference and I've got a
two hour workshop on G RPC or I won't be
mentioning WCF but I will be showing you
a lot more detail about creating gr PC
applications from scratch thank you very
much
[Applause]